I'm stir grant from the long now
foundation welcome to a different venue
for the seminars about long-term
thinking I want to make one space
related announcement from one out some
of you may know that we've been involved
for several years a project called the
Rosetta project which is gonna tell
Rosetta project everything that's
putting increasingly all the languages
in the world online and one place but it
originally started out as a de is an
attempt to truth that you do serious
photocopy in a non-digital away when
trying to get out of the wonderful demo
here which I'll wait instead the young a
martyr second just a couple of weeks ago
a rocket it will be Ariane 5 looks like
you can tell it's French
the ariane 5 French guinea into a 11
year mission this is not this is slow
space exploration to go to a comment
which rejoices in a virtually got to go
to the comic rotana but they missed the
launch window forth so instead it's
going to the comet 67p
churyumov-gerasimenko and said how much
for mrs. son three eccentric orbit about
every six and a half years 11 years the
Rosetta project which is what it's all
that's why they want to put here was
that it is on it a lil ronny we live
comin and then land on an attached to it
will be to first much as it was with the
moon one of the land of comment another
orbit in the disc three engineering disc
with a thousand languages represented on
a micro rest of the same text and images
from long now is will be there orbiting
that on so with any time in the future
somebody wants to
find out a thousand of the languages
that were expand the world back and then
finished called 21st century what will
be able to find them so that's longhouse
contribution space questions records
contribution to space is enormous
distension a thing or two besides what's
in your introduction Carter there for
some kind of rusty in the late 60s I was
doing whole earth stuff basically
pushing but the image of the earth of
the states would do for people and what
I was served raining and loading rusty
was actually doing and he one of giving
a talk to a kind of philosophical group
on the East Coast that I got a recording
up and we wound up printing it in the
co-evolution quarterly it's an article
the title was no frames no boundaries
and would say basically telling them
what happened with rusty and the pollen
on mission he was the first to go eda
without an umbilical he went outside to
Ronnie earth space with nothing but a
tether holding him to the space of an
afternoon and while he was out there
doing work there is a delay and he had
some time to do nothing but hanging
there in space
they call themselves watching the earth
stroll live and something you're
evocative happen and the realization
that he was in a situation where II was
looking thru window he was looking for
television he was he was in the big view
/ no brains everywhere he looked resolve
States and where he was looking was down
at the earth we're going to go there in
her robberies and it was all connected
in a very non critical way and basically
what he was seeing was and since all of
us public life and also realizing that
his next to that being a live person
wanting to go back there but also being
outside he in a sense was representing
life looking at itself in the large
scale for almost the first time and he
had a privilege of being life cycle for
a short while out there and like many of
the astronauts he was never the same out
of that and since then he's gotten
interested in other near-earth objects
and he's here too
thank you very much Stewart the
proximate reason that I'm here is
because Stewart and I are doing some
work in Canada last year for the
Canadian nuclear waste management
organization who are a new group of
people part of Canadian government who
have been assigned the responsibility
for figuring out how to safely and
responsibly feel with their waste in
Canada and in that process the question
came up as they're looking obviously
long-term fits right into the long
downtown right one of the questions was
you know over 10,000 years we're trying
to store this stuff and beyond that
responsibly we need to worry about a
thorough near-earth asteroid cities and
I said probably have to think about it
and so Stewart had to be there that
session as well he said that would be
pretty interesting our little Friday
jobs so that's how I got it okay how
about talking about the asteroids read
over the next hundred thousand years now
I would normally not start off this way
I'm going to work
see the screen myself good luck opening
it's on the stand off to the side here I
hope I am I still audible in the back
okay all right so uh okay so the first
question of course is you know what's
red they want to talk about the little
cosmic environment some options for
action in fact because this is an
actionable bit of intelligence and in
the end I want to ram a little bit about
my feelings and I thought about the
evolutionary context of what it is we're
talking about Earth well this is what
we're talking about in terms of the
threat in this particular instance this
is an artist image of what the choo
chooooo impact down the Uptown Peninsula
might have looked like this is the one
that you would recall occurred 65
million years ago and wiped out the
dinosaurs and about 75% of all species
the word alive on the planet earth at
that time got some more artists
conceptions of the same various images
of what it might have been like but what
I want to do with the asset here just so
you get a feeling for this and recognize
that this is an extremely exceptional
event this is not a normal what we might
expect you know a lot of nevertheless
this has happened many times to the
earth the most recent one being 65
million years
this side diagram is start troubles
probably this one up here when one of
these asteroids this particular one that
came in was about ten kilometers across
this is actually the bad drawing in
terms of scale but the actual impact it
was about ten to twelve auditors in
diameter when that comes sailing in at
about 47,000 miles an hour to an impact
it not only explodes and vaporizes
itself but it literally sends up digs
out excavates from the earth billions of
tons of the earth and screws it up into
the air and vaporizes a lot of it most
of it its ends up at near escape
velocity is about five percent of the
ejecta actually escaped back into space
most of the terrestrial material not the
original asteroid material and of course
you have an incredible shock wave a
seismic shock that goes out you have a
tsunami which is created instantaneously
huge waves that would have gone well
into Texas in fact probably pass the
northern boundaries of Texas for example
but those in subsets are the local
events and those are going to be
happening within a matter of
a few minutes but most of this stuff
that gets thrown up into the air as i
said billions of tons of rock ends up
coming down because it goes up into
ballistic trajectories out through the
atmosphere into space and like an ICBM
each one of these billions of ICBMs
little ones end up raining down all over
the earth not just locally but around
the whole earth so they go out on
looping trajectories as many of them
have come raining back down through the
atmosphere of course when this happens
they become incandescent as they come
back down through the atmosphere as any
reentering body would become a result of
that is that you literally have around
the planet say 12 hours or 45 minutes to
two hours after the impact you've got
these incandescent rocks early down
through the atmosphere landing all over
the planet the temperature of the sky
after about an hour he comes on to the
city of 1,500 degrees centigrade the
result of that is that you have
instantaneous flash fires spontaneous
combustion of all vegetation around a
planet not only do you have a for spend
all of the toxic gases and things found
in molten rock and hot rocks falling but
you also have a lot of stuff and smoke
again totally filling the atmosphere so
for a matter of several days you
probably have confirmation
around the earth at the same time with
all the students log there once the fire
is burning stuff out now you have a
total darkness because no sunlight
reaches the surface for as much as two
years after that but this size once of
course the whole chain of life or most
of it disappears this particular case
about 75% of all species the reason it's
not another person is several
interesting reasons but it turns out
when you do the detailed analysis
microphones difficult bear with me when
you do the detailed analysis when you
find in the same way that lava flows
will cover the Island of Hawaii
nevertheless they always see little
islands normally call it the hookahs to
sure okay so there's a name for these
little islands if the lava flowed is all
around but you always have certain
regions of somewhere around here's where
it didn't burn it didn't have enough of
it in fall to create the same
devastation as a result you have refugia
for life in various places and once the
the nuclear winter disappears life
begins to re-emerge let me give you one
other factoid on this again with the
atmosphere that something like 1500
agree centigrade from something like
this in an event of this size the chick
the loop impact about it is thought that
about one meter of the ocean surface
boil the web in this event there are
impacts that have occurred on the earth
in which all of the water it's about
fifty percent probability will get
throughout the life of the planet
200-meter a stir in which case is a
total ocean with a boil long so these
are huge events that we're talking about
here potentially 200 200 when I Center
nativa Twitter kilometer thank you well
let's come down to a more frequent event
this is the the Tunguska event that
occurred in 1908 Siberia this was a very
small about a 60 meter diameter an
asteroid that came in it never reached
the ground in fact until they're about
150 meters in diameter they will end up
exploding as air burst not hit the
ground depends a bit on the comp is
the asteroid but in this case it was a
60-meter of asteroid came and exploded
at about 18,000 feet 20,000 feet the
explosive force was about 10 megatons
equivalent of energy and without
creating a career at all in the forest
Siberia it nevertheless blew down 2,100
square kilometers of forest as we
flattened it and burned it if you
superpose that 2,100 square kilometers
along the City of London this is what
you get if you instead of writing out
one person that's happened here or
reindeer herder apparently you would
have wiped out what 8 million people or
something like that City of London so
it's all aware comes down at the
facility end of the scale from time to
time a rock comes through somebody's
ceiling ends up in their basement or in
your bedroom or in this particular case
a woman's car got penetrated by an
asteroid fragment in Peekskill New York
and these things you're reading the
papers in every couple of months
actually somewhere in the world well you
know we're not alone innocent you know
you don't have to be a rocket scientist
to figure out you look at the moon
it's characterized by creators of all
different sizes in fact everywhere you
looked at the solar system here's murder
3 and again at the large scale or the or
detail scale what you're seeing on crate
craters craters proofs of course those
craters are all caused by not all but
almost all caused by asteroids that have
enacted these bodies over the life of
the solar system this is Mars here
you're seeing signs of an atmosphere and
erosion features and sand dunes things
of that kind but nevertheless you've got
craters also all through it when you get
to oh this is a couldn't pass up a shot
of ours this is looking straight down on
Olympus Mons the largest volcano in the
solar system this is about three times
as high as Mount Everest about 23 27
kilometers high five hundred kilometers
across and even though you have a
caldera here a volcanic caldera at the
top on the side slopes you've got impact
craters even even there so here we have
our share on earth these are the
sampling of about three of c-23 of about
190 or 200 or so that we know now
that we found that it's on earth it's me
your career in Arizona about 1.2
kilometers wolf creek and australia the
medical wagon impact crater in the
Canadian Shield this one is about 70
kilometers across now it was originally
about hundred kilometers across but it's
a really down so these things come in
many sizes and many different shades
once in a while although I won't talk
about that much tonight because it's
only about 1% a portion of the threat
comes from comments but it turns out
that in 1994 an awful lot of attention
got shifted to their master dates and
impacts in general because Carolyn
shoemaker was looking at a photographic
plate one evening when they were looking
for near-earth asteroids and she saw
this very strange shaped in the
photographic plate when they blew it up
does he want it turned out to be and it
was in fact a comet which was broken up
going around close pass by judor broken
to 23 to 27 fragments all of the people
at JPL and orbital
conditions from all around the world had
a ball trying to forecast precisely what
its orbit would being and found out that
an impact on Jupiter and in the end
predicted the impacts which happened
around the limb of Jupiter within
accuracy of one minute so it was sort of
the first test of actually in fact it
was the first time that anyone had ever
witnessed a major impact on anything in
the solar system saw the evidence of it
afterward lots of it but this is the
first time that anyone ever watched one
and of course because we had a year
warning due mainly to Caroline shipping
is this president gene who was also
famous in his own right David leading
because they found this about a year
ahead of the impact not only most people
who are interested in astronomy we're
watching it but Hubble telescope all
kinds of other tell us effective just
about every telescope in the world was
focused on Jupiter that night and it was
incredible when these huge impacts
happened and less blemishes and tutor so
what are these things well then this is
a picture similar scale of three
asteroids that we have visited
close and personal in fact we have
visited now if you count both competent
asteroids 11 of these bodies with
spacecraft from Earth this is Matilda
over here and gastro and this is eros I
mean item excuse me that there are
obviously not that close season just put
together but they're all to the same
scale and this scale is about 60 60
kilometers here in the long dimension
this is about 60 x 23 yourself just to
give you the scale so let's look at what
do we see here we'll the first the most
obvious thing is that with the exception
of Matilda over here they're not spirit
this one is not an officer well there
are lots of them which are even less
spherical than I than item over here
second thing you see is craters so even
asteroids get hit by asteroids in fact
if you look at the tilde over here let
me point out this crater here another
one on the top it's about the same size
you've got a crater here quite literally
half the size of the asteroid it's up
now when you look at that and you have
any sense of structural mechanics the
big question is how in the world do you
form a creator like that without having
bourbon to the asteroid apart so from
this and lots of other more detailed
evidence which has occurred we have come
that many of these asteroids have gone
most certainly the larger ones in fact
are there a bit like a marshmallow or
big piece of styrofoam you're kicking
and make a dent in it but it just
absorbs the impact that it doesn't
shatter these are not big solid pieces
of rock in fact they're pretty much
thought to be highly fractured rock
almost loosely assembled boulders with a
bunch of dust spread between them
they're generally called by people in
the business rubble piles they're
loosely held together by gravity but
there's not much structural strength
there it turns out that Ida happens to
have a companion that is called dactyl
it was the first case of a binary
asteroid that we found they come in
pairs sometimes about fifteen percent of
near-earth asteroids or asteroids in
general that we found our turn out to be
binaries and that's an interesting thing
because when you have a binary now
they're rotating around one another
because that you can figure out in fact
the mass of the larger one the massive
through highly different in size you can
determine the mass of the larger
asteroid larger partner if you know the
mass and you can certainly calculate the
volume through the photography now you
have the dentary and the density of
these asteroids many of them turn out to
be very very low the basic rock of which
they're comprised has a specific gravity
of about three or four thriller three or
four times more dense than water but
these in fact the bulk density is down
in the basicity of 22 grams per cubic
centimeter what that tells you is
because they're made it have to be made
of rock and metals well then it tells
you which is a lot of empty space in
those things so that styrofoam bottle is
okay except the fact starve them has a
lot of structure activity but these are
not what you might think that big solid
rocks in general some of them are very
few well these happen to be main-belt
asteroids this one is the first
near-earth asteroid was ever discovered
it also is the largest one this is the
asteroid eros 433 the near shoemaker
mission flew around us for over a year
we've got a lot of information on this
it's the largest of the year
26 kilometers long so it's very large
which is why it was the first one
discovered we're back around 1946 before
we go any further let's do a little bit
in terms of terms and definitions you'll
hear me talk about near-earth objects
and Neos they're asteroids and short
period comets whose orbits cross or
nearly cross the orbit of the earth the
two terms are almost interchangeable and
Nia would be a near-earth asteroid in
fact about 99% of the Neos are in fact
asteroids and not your short-term comics
short period comets the same way of the
potentially hazardous was it as a subset
of the near-earth objects which if you
project out a hundred years or so have a
closest approach of about nineteen lunar
distances they come within 19 lunar
distances of the earth or let's say a
period of hundred years we call these
potentially hazardous objects because if
one swings by Mars for example or even
another near-earth object close enough
their orbits can be distorted to the
point where they will impact the earth
so that ends up being about a twenty one
percent of the total
halation we put in the potentially
hazardous category and the same thing
for PHAs for asteroids the spaceguard
survey is the current search program
which is looking for tracking and
cataloging all these near Earth
asteroids and the goal of that program
is to within a period of ten years
ascertain 1998 in 10 years to catalog
ninety percent of all of the air earth
asteroids over one kilometer in diameter
only the big ones those are those the
crowd shoulders and we'll get into that
event there's now a new report that has
just come out which is basically
recommended after many years of
everybody pushing it to move that one
column or target down to 100 to 140
meters because while these are the ones
that do damage around the whole planet
in fact you have a lot of damage created
by the smaller ones that I haven't much
more frequently so the current
recommendation is to go down too much
smaller size so let's look at let's look
at where these guys are this is not what
I learned in elementary school this is
the main asteroid belt between Mars and
Jupiter out here with Mercury Venus and
the earth and here Mars orbit so each of
these green dots is a known and numbered
ask naked elf asteroid you can pick any
number you want for the total
asteroids in the main belt but if you
don't pick one that has nine zeros I did
wrong but of course those things don't
stay there they do for let's say
billions of years hundreds of millions
of years but there are resonances
created by the plan Jupiter and these
things occasionally get bounced out of
their orbits and end up into the inner
part of the solar system and these red
dots which are completely expanded here
are all near-earth asteroids these are
asteroids which now loop into the inner
solar system some of them are near
circular orbits some of them loop all
the way back down to Jupiter and back in
these are not static here you can't
picture these as stay there then this is
a snapshot of all these things but now
let me point out that this is all you're
seeing here are the current near-earth
asteroids that happen to be within the
inner solar system instead of those that
have leaked out and are out here at the
moment as of about this is about a month
ago so you're talking about something
like a cup of thousand maybe maybe a
little less if you go down to 140 meters
or let's say 100 meter
diameter instead of talking you know a
couple thousand you're talking on the
order of a billion of these things so
the whole inner solar cookie would be
filled with red dots of this size so
when people talk about in this business
that the earth is literally orbiting the
Sun in a shooting gallery that's quite
literally what legitimate state to make
that even more explicitly let me run you
from June the first of two thousand one
to Jim the first the 2002 in a little
movie for the friend of mine in Europe
made for me the earth is the blue dot
here these are for near-earth asteroids
and for others will enter into the
picture here in a second this is actual
data from the year from this one here
and these are only eight but they're the
eight that came closest to the earth for
that particular year but this is what it
looks like if you have the eye of God
looking down with all this and now in
your mind is to go through this what you
want to do is multiply the number of
these things by you know 100,000 or
something
and multiply one year by of you a
Stewart did a hundred thousand years and
you get some idea of the fact that it's
only a matter of time before we run into
these things now to give you a slightly
different field this is again done by my
same friend at what he did here was he
took together earth here and now he
plotted all of the known potentially
hazardous asteroids whoever this is only
twenty one percent of the total dome is
and what he did was was just bought one
year of all of the known dhas and again
as soon as we get the detection programs
really cranked up for the smaller guys
we're going to end up populating this
space with a thousand times as many of
these guys now of course I you know I
probably don't need to point out the
most of it that the size of these dots
is much much larger than the actual size
of the asteroid in terms of this
perspective even the earth is much
smaller than the size of that dot so
they look like they hit here but they
actually don't nevertheless there is a
real world and we're living on and he
sings do have fun night sighs so this
this looks complicated I want you to
forget about this box up here and forget
it up most of this stuff picture this
graph and just that big dotted enough
dog is a dashed blue line because that's
really what what the assume population
your own asteroids is and I'll explain
this chart a bit because it's important
to get a picture here here you have the
number of the number of years before an
impact of any given size so let's just
say for example this is a log scale so
this is powers of 10 so 10 to the 0 is 1
so that what that means is every year
we're going to have an asteroid of that
size hit the earth those over to the
blue line up there and what that says is
we're going to have about a what it's
going to be about the energy is about it
that's 10 to the minus two so that's 10
mega times soon as Megan I so there's a
hundred kilotons there's 10 kiloton so
we're look at about three or four killer
x three or four kiloton impact every
year that means something that's about
four meters in diameter enters into the
earth history earth every year gives you
about a three kiloton explosion that's
on an annual basis I was very
interesting because a couple of years
ago in fact that without you just a
little over a year at the height of the
tension between Pakistan and India one
of these things in fact a little bit
larger than that
they turned out to be about a 12 kiloton
explosion occurred over the
Mediterranean where a near-earth
asteroid entered in and exploded if the
earthy only turns slightly less at the
time had happened two hours earlier it
would have occurred right over Pakistan
and tell me now if the India the
Pakistanis would not have thought that
that was an Indian nuclear weapon so
these things can have real consequences
excitement coming down deeper and
hitting people on ground well that's a
small you know those are small ones once
a year let's go down here to a hundred
million years ten to eight okay at a
hundred liters we're going to have that
that's something like six hundred ten to
the eighth megatons so 60 mega 60,000
megatons and that's about a ten
kilometer object sized object and that's
going to happen once every every ten be
able to once every hundred million years
and that's that in fact it's a chick
salud with it we saw earlier to wipe out
the dinosaurs so Stuart's test here was
what happens in the next hundred
thousand years well here we go 100,000
years ten to the fifth we come in here
and what we've got is about a 6,000 mega
time ten to the fourth is of 10,000 so
that's about 6,000 big event as a result
of a 500-meter there's one long or so
the 500 meter
I impact and you can think any size that
you want go up there and figure out how
often they're going to hit this this
chart is in a sense the compilation of
all of the analysis which says what is
the population of these guys what is
statistically what do we got what kind
of an environment are we operating in
now just to then make that explicit for
my friend here in the next hundred
thousand years would likely to see 1 500
meter asteroid you about 6,000 megatons
blown off but at the same time we're
going to see em 200-meter asteroid
impacts four hundred mega times the
largest nuclear weapon ever gave IQ
matter is made by the Soviets and it's
about 65 times so that gives you an idea
but you got to put together about seven
of them come up to two that and you know
100 not there and of course it keeps
going so we should see in that same
100,000 years about 170 meter asteroid
impacts this is a little bit larger than
the Tunguska event
show you early so you clearly wipe it
out even more interesting in some sense
there's about a ten percent probability
in a hundred thousand years that we
would be hit by a 1.2 kilometer dire
impact that that has global effects now
we're dealing with a mini chicken kind
of effect it's not going to create
extinction probably the mate way by the
way that might point out the human race
but it certainly was going to leave a
lot of more resilient animals again to
put it in a little more direct
perspective here's the vulgate bridge
there's our 500 meter asteroid s it will
talk about and this is an actual
asteroid put again to scale this is
another binder in one of the binary
asteroids that we found the primaries
800 meters of the secondary is 300
meters of diameter but this is our 500
meter to scale with a golden gate bridge
well what happens on these things hit
but what do we talking about in terms of
the consequences this is another one of
those same plot so we just point out
here this is great 20 kilometers per
second that's about the average velocity
that one of these things has under
impacts your foot it's here so if you
follow that dash line that's the average
that they're faster you know for any
other sides down here obviously if
you're dealing with the faster speeds
you have greater destruction this is the
radius of destruction and kilometers
here you see you know the area of Los
Angeles let me give you a couple of
examples there's our this is the radius
of the diameter so 500 meter diameter
object which is the one that we just
figured we're going to get hit 100,000
years intersects that line up here so
you got about a hundred ten kilometer
radius of total destruction these curves
are pretty well known it's not a lot of
uncertainty here because we've been
screwing around with nuclear weapons for
a long time so we had a really good idea
of what happens when you have Megaton
events floating off I mean it's quite a
well-known thing so these are these are
quite accurate if on the other hand we
have 10 of our 200
there are yeah it's been a 200-meter
asteroids those things are going to
create about well what three times the
area of Los Angeles or something like
that two and a half times the area of
los angeles gets wiped out 10 times in a
hundred thousand years and a hundred
times and a hundred thousand years we've
got these little guys 70 meters in
diameter and they wiped out something
just about the size of Los Angeles only
a hundred times during that hundred
thousand years so that's that's what
we're talking about now I'm going to
grant you that we're talking so far
statistical data everything I've talked
about is its statistical but it's based
on actual observations the statistics
that we get all these things we one of
the voyeurs i get an example just look
at the moon and count the creators of
different sizes you can figure out you
know it was a ten Megaton impacting
creases created SSO you count up all
those you / 5 million years and you get
the flux of of asteroids that size
that's on that chart i showed you a
little while ago that's one of the ways
you figure out the population but there
are many other ways so the statistics
that we have are quite accurate so when
i start talking about you know 10 or 100
of these things different sizes is with
fairly high confidence today that we can
say these statistically at least this
will happen okay but what about the
reality we are actually observing and
searching for these things and finding
them and cataloging them so when we find
them then what we do is we take one out
of these
mystical category and put it into the
known category so if there are for
example let's say of people largely is
the once over one kilometer we now know
that there are about 1,100 of those
things total out there and at this point
we've discovered 700 of them we've
actually seen them to tell us if we
measure their orbits and we project
ahead a hundred years with the accuracy
of the tracking that we have you can
project reliably for about a hundred
years we can say right now that no not a
single one 700 in fact is going to hit
the earth in the next hundred years now
on the other hand the other four hundred
that we haven't seen one could hit
tomorrow they've been hit a hundred
years now and thousand years from now
but you know that's still in a
statistical category but in a sense
we've retired or we've diminished the
statistical probability by finding these
things and when we finding we find so
far not one would that none of them are
going to hit us in the next hundred
years however as we start going to
smaller and smaller asteroids the
population gets much higher we get hit
much more frequently so it's really only
a matter of time when we go down to
asteroids the vicinity of 70 or 80
meters in diameter that we're going to
find one with our number one and that's
the importance of the search programs
to both provide some reassurance we're
not about to get whacked tomorrow but at
the same time when we do find one that's
got our number on it we in all
likelihood is not going to be hitting us
for decades in other words you pick
these things up as they go by the earth
fairly near the earth and you project
that ahead and it's going to go around
the Sun you know they're our neighbors
circulate around the neighborhood for
for millions of years and so by
projecting the motion unlike our
neighbors reality we can't really
predict how to move around the
neighborhood it these are very
predictable one of the wonderful thing
he says storytelling 111 one of the
wonderful things about warble mechanics
here about Newton and his buddies is it
you know there are very few weird things
out there there's no friction that I've
action so you can project what ahead of
time and you can say with 30 good
knowledge you measure to arc seconds of
accuracy with radar even measure two
millimeters per second or velocity so
you can you can make pretty good
predictions I'll give you the example of
the extreme of that which was asked
50 da it created a stir about two and a
half three years ago when astronomers
saw it and looked as though in fact that
some of us when you first see one of
these things your accuracy of
measurement is not so great because
you've only tracked it for a short
period of time and therefore there's an
error band around what you're seeing
what you're measuring and in fact if you
project out ahead of years that Astrid
spreads out into a huge error ellipse
and you know it's really not very
certain whether it's going to get you're
not but some of the potential solutions
show that there would be an intersection
with the earth so people started looking
at these things and the astronomers went
back and history one of the things you
do is to project backward in time just
as this thing can see before you look on
photographic plates databases lo and
behold they found out it was first seen
in 1950 so now you've got like 50 years
of data points now where it was 50 years
ago where it is now the result of that
is you have a very precise knowledge of
that particular era vastra now we can
say right now the nineteen fifty da has
a one and three hundred genes of impact
on March 16th 2880 and I'm not kidding
that's literally the statistical reality
of that s true now it's an exception
most of the time we only have enough
data to project a hundred years but
that's that's what we're looking for is
that kind of ability to project out so
in the general case when you detect one
of these asteroids it's not about the
issue it goes around the Sun many many
times and then three decades from now
five decades from now 85 years 2880 you
see yes indeed we're going to be the
same place in space at the same time
does that answer so the detection
program that is awfully important if you
want to do something about these things
we don't just want to know where they
are and catalogue we want to know how
are they going to hit us if they are it
is 20 or 30 years from now let's take
some action so here we're now going to
get into the idea of deflection and this
is what I'm especially involved in and
so part of the rest of the talk will be
in this area there are two general types
of ideas with deflection of an asteroid
you got to push the suckers one way or
about it right so you can either push
them impulsively that isn't a heart
quick hit of some kind of nuclear
explosion or directly impacted or you
have another set of techniques would you
slow controlled acceleration either get
up against and actually push it very
slowly or you boil off the surface with
a laser concentrated you're a lazy and
when you boil off the surface castor
other way just to give you a quick
summary of the results of this and we're
not going to belabor this but the direct
impact technique impulsive technique is
is not very practical it turns out that
you don't hit it in the right direction
unless you make an exceptional design
and if you do that then the cost looks
out of sight it's not a very effective
way to change the orbit of one of these
asteroids nuclear explosion is a little
bit more effective of course there are
another bunch of problems in terms of
treaty violations of weapons in space
there are a lot of unknowns because
remember these things are like kicking a
marshmallow so you blow off a nuclear
weapon next 21 and they just sit there
absorber make a little Jennifer litter
but you don't know what's going to
happen and you have to know an awful lot
about the end you want to deflect it you
don't want to go up there and say oh we
didn't use quite enough so there's a lot
of unknowns about the effect of nuclear
weapons sort of nuclear explosions on
these objects so it's very asteroid
characteristic dependent and if you
think about defending the earth against
an impactor you know ad infinitum what
that means is you're going to have to
have nuclear weapons hanging around you
ad infinitum and I dare say that the
proliferation and accidental issues
create more risk can be solved by
deflecting asterism one the other
techniques of Alicia it's relatively
controlled but there are major optical
system problems there are a lot of
problems with those techniques the final
one is the simple one but it sounds
simple as a lot more complex and it
sounds you go up there in the land don't
ever grab a hold of it are attached to
it and then you push with your rocket
engine your plasma engine or whatever
for a long time and slowly you change
the orbit of the asteroid so let's let's
just take a moment to go over this a
little bit let me show you the impact
geometry we're looking at the earth here
or the mcdonald ears at night it's
Florida East Coast and this is the trace
through space of an impact point on the
earth in other words we're going to have
an asteroid hit somewhere here and
that's the path that that impact point
based in space here's the path of the
asteroid that impacts and the intersect
right here they get there at the same
time this is the velocity vector if you
want to vector stuff that's the velocity
vector of the asteroid and that's the
velocity vector of the impact point and
it's the difference between those two
vectors in other words it appears if
you're sitting at that place on earth
the Astro doesn't appear to come in like
this it appears to command this way like
that okay it's a difference between them
so that's that that's what we're looking
at what we need to do now it turns out
that if you want to avoid an impact the
most efficient
you can do is to change the size of the
orbit of the asteroid you do that by
pushing it along its velocity but you
need to speed it up or you slow it down
you don't push it sideways because that
doesn't do anything for you and I'll
show you that in a minute but what what
the right thing to do here is to slow
down the asteroid so that after you put
on it it ends up being back here when
that impact point is there and it goes
fine past the earth of hitting it so
here we are out of orbit the Earth orbit
and there's our 2004 hypothetical one
asteroid and what we want to do is push
on that asteroid at this point
perihelion that is closest point to the
Sun and if you push on it there and
increase its velocity very very slightly
this orbit will get slightly larger very
very slightly larger and therefore
because the orbit is slightly larger it
will take longer around the Sun so
here's our task is again this is with a
slow push but even with a nuclear weapon
here you can do the same thing going to
push on that ass for a near or in this
case we push on it from here for 200
days till it's around there and by the
time we get there if we do it right we
have increased the velocity of that
asteroid by 170 their per second that's
all that's required that's about to
hundreds of a mile per hour increase in
his speed which is already 47,000 miles
an hour so you're now going 47,000 2
point 0 0 1 0 that's all you have to do
and what happens is that the period of
the or
increases by something like 40 seconds
and so can I orbits later it's going to
be four minutes lady for the Robin Hood
okay so listen let's look at that
there's our impact point and the
asteroid there's our vectors again
there's the original impact so after we
pushed up the sucker for 50 days it's
back here why the impact point the
original attack point was there so if we
spot after 50 days which God forbid were
not planning to do it would now hit here
and if after a hundred days of pushing
on it it would get here and would be
back here at the time which are original
impact points there 150 days we end up
the point here that we call the liftoff
point in other words that asteroid would
then just graze the surface of the earth
and after that it's up in the atmosphere
and out into space you know so we have a
deflection gold target point out here so
after 200 days of pushing that's what
we've done in the process we've created
what we call a deflection path or I
prefer to call it a path of risk because
if we fail somewhere in the middle of
this instead of this act of God
occurring here we now have an act of
humankind occurring here here or here so
this is a non trivial matter when you
start reflecting one of these things
because you put additional people at
risk that weren't originally in order to
save everybody that will be one hole
again okay well all the sounds great am
I just standing up you're waving my arms
is this possible can we can we go up
there and take something
ways you know a billion kilograms a
million metric tons and actually push on
it changes velocity I mean how arrogant
is that right changing the cosmics well
in fact right now in NASA there is a
program called the mission actually
called the jupiter icy moons order jimoh
this mission is part of what nasa refers
to as the prometheus program the
Prometheus program is a program which is
to to basically develop the capabilities
which will enable humankind to operate
routinely beyond low-earth orbit not
just after the geostationary orbit or at
low Earth orbit the way we do today but
to make routine human operations with
revived and manned missions of human
missions in deep space beyond low birth
order well what it takes of course are
some new technologies and these new
technologies have been worked on from
years and are today in prototype form
this is not just paperwork we're talking
about things that are actually typed in
the laboratory and turning slowly into
actual production capability a space
nuclear power is one because what you
have to do is have very high efficiency
electric propulsion iron propulsion and
Lori phone
engines as you know or plasma engines
which are even more powerful and
efficient and all of them take a lot of
electricity especially if you want hi
sources not you know building pounds but
you know but several pounds of force and
so what we're talking about is a
spacecraft here which has plasma or I
engines on the back end relatively
little fuel because the engines are
extremely efficient but a lot of
electricity from a nuclear power reactor
up here and these are radiators to
reject all the heat now it turns out
that when a group of us probably started
out 40 of us in October of 2001 we're
very concerned because we realize that
the detection programs are finding more
and more of these near Earth asteroids
we keep having all kinds of stairs and
impressed because one comes flying
relatively nearby or gets all excited
but sooner or later with a detection
program accelerating the way it is we're
going to have a real announcement that
there is an asteroid headed for the
earth I don't know what that's going to
happen could happen tomorrow could have
a 100
now or anywhere in between but it's
going to happen and what happens in the
general public when they hear of an
asteroid is going to be impact in the
earth the first question is well who's
NASA must be doing some of that right
answer no nobody's doing a damn thing
about so the group of us got together
and decided that you know this is a real
enough issue that we felt that quietly
somebody ought to actually be doing the
work that would enable a student number
one can we do anything about it and if
we can hypothetically let's come up with
some designs less actually do something
serious about this so we formed an
organization called the b612 foundation
now some of you in this room may know
his tell you the b612 is because that's
the name of the asteroid that little
prince lived on so the little princes
are here he was there first right here
in his robes so the b612 foundation we
formed reducing cultivation of 501 C 3
you know public charity ready to check
please do through the address maybe our
goal is to alter the orbit of an
asteroid in a controlled manner by 2015
we load that the technologies looked at
the development schedules and decided
that 20
teen was actually an achievable date by
which we could actually move an asteroid
now we're not talking about deflecting
all the way from the earth we're talking
about demonstrating the capability to
show humanity that in fact we now have
the technologies in hand which will
enable us for the first time in the
history of humanity to actually control
our destiny in this extended sense so
that purpose was to demonstrate its not
to actually key point from hitting the
earth is is to demonstrate to that
capability today exists when people
realize that number one if an
announcement comes instead of panic
passages panic is public panic is
fostered by whether the individual level
or the collective level by a sense of
being out of control of your destiny by
having a demonstrated example that we
can actually move one of these days even
a little bit there's a hope people sense
then there's a chance plus the fact
you're going to discover it probably 20
or 30 years of war hopefully before it
impacts so our job because we ended up
designing our project around the
Prometheus technologies and in fact to
see a lot of similarity here where we've
landed on and grabbed a hold of this
asteroid with
our space ground that's an example of
Scientific American from november 2003
our job then is to convince that i will
put convincing quotes i probably should
have done it there but to convince nasa
to incorporate the b612 mission in the
previous program they're going to fly
these Prometheus spacecraft anyway well
before well about 2015 so what we're
saying is instead of going out you know
to play footsie to Pluto you know let's
go out and develop the capability of
landing on asteroids and other great
things to mine there's tremendous
resources and those ask water oxygen you
can use it to go further out into space
you can use it to help a colony living
on an asteroid or whatever because
resources out there they can be used in
space in fact you can do commercial
mining commercial manufacturing
eventually online asteroids in addition
you can learn a lot about the origins of
the solar system and in fact the origins
of life in the solar system by studying
scientifically the asteroids the same
way you can learn life in the comments
like Rosetta tentative but in addition
to that as a side benefit hey you get
the push
around two and again push you away from
an impact with the earth okay so that's
that's really the main part of the story
now I want to come to to the more
philosophical part and frankly to a part
that is when I look at myself I care
about obviously a potential impact but
what I really think about what we're
talking about here what I find
fascinating is the scope of what we're
doing in terms of the life of or life in
the universe some of you who are older
they remember when the fate of the earth
book by Jonathan shell was written
somewhere back in the 70s I think it
sort of a height of the Cold War
Jonathan shells book was really seminal
for me I can remember to this day here
in front of her Diana city and open our
living room abusive reading reading this
book and I can remember getting to the
part where he very graphically in a very
personal way illustrates the fundamental
difference between me dying or us dying
or a few of us dying and extinction of
life they're very very different and so
low why I got out of that book
was like a club over the head was there
is a there is a qualitative difference a
huge qualitative difference between
individuals or groups of individuals
dying and extinction of life of humanity
or whatever well the other side of that
coin is that living is not the same as
immortality and what we're talking about
here for this capability is meeting one
of the two basic prerequisites for
immortality immortality is going to
require two things it's going to require
eliminating those things where you're
going to create extinction of life I
pointed out earlier with check Shalhoub
but also with a 200-meter 200 kilometer
diameter impact you always be sterilized
a surface of a planet I actually things
even survived that but that's a
different story in any event what
happens here periodically in the whole
history of the earth is a place starts
up it begins to diversify and form a
tree of life and along comes this crazy
cosmic gardener and go to whack with his
machete and wipes out you know a couple
of branches off the tree of life and
then nuclear winter goes away and the
greenhouse effect happens in love online
finally the stuff starts coming up again
and just like in your garden when you
cut things they start growing all
different kinds of ways they bloom again
the tree of life starts exploding along
comes another swipe by the cosmic garden
right that's where we are today I'm
going to point out something to people
they don't realize think about the
dinosaurs they got moved out 65 to 80
years ago if the dinosaurs didn't get
never made it we made it because the
dinosaurs bidon that's why we're here
we're now on the top of the heat
question is that we're going to be like
the dinosaurs but before I get into that
let me look at the dinosaurs 65 million
years ago let's picture when that is
mentally that's a long long time ago but
if the earth were formed on January one
a year ago and it's January one be your
leader now when was that december twenty
seventh and we just happened so it's
important to understand that that crazy
cosmic gardener not only whack life back
billions of years ago shortly after the
formation of life but it just ended on
december the 27th the next time but now
for the first time we have the
opportunity to interrupt that process to
stop that crazy cosmic garter from
screwin up our immortality at least this
vision this is local spot on the
university the second requirement for
immortality is to diversify your
location and again through all these
technologies that we keep inventing work
gradually that in
if you want to extend a couple thousand
years out you can picture that the fact
we can be going not only other planets
but maybe two other those stellar
systems so once you get to that point
now is you know there is this
possibility of life the experiment i
call this great experiment in life
continuing beyond just the confines of
the earth and that's an amazing thing
that that capability is with us right
now so the question is do we take
responsibility for life in this part of
the universe now I have no doubt that
length exists elsewhere in this huge
universe in which we live we're not an
exception I can't prove that but you
should have a hell of job convincing you
that life that has existed elsewhere in
the universe runs into the same problem
this is not a solar system problem this
is any planetary system challenger
problem any life which is existed
elsewhere in the universe and survived
has gone past this point I have no doubt
that others did not so this is a very
interesting cosmic evolution moment in
time when we find ourselves now you know
I'm not going to be able to sell this
broken to NASA
on that basis letter one of my local
congressperson but nevertheless I think
it did something which you fall asleep
and I thinking kind of the ball over and
figure out whether you're on border
around the word right decision once
every guy okay so without I'm going to
stop the wide part of it ask your
questions and we'll shoot for there
thank you very much
well certain the most challenging and
Pierce of the questions I have to have
some inside knowledge that I'm going to
pose to Rusty which is I oh he was just
at a gathering of Southern Californians
and newspapers the other day almost a
whole bunch of the asteroid workers are
out there and you saw the slide again
which show that there are two ways to
move in a furnace is impulsive course
and things like we're explosion and then
there's the slow wonderful losing a long
you seem to prefer what's what's the
problem with nuclear propulsion and have
a common thing every siblings or a bomb
hear it and knock it out and who
actually wants to do it that way well I
think you know the general sense of
things you're dealing with these huge
massive objects that are going like a
bat out of hell and have a tremendous
amount of energy and all that is
absolutely true so the general sense of
things is that if you're dealing with
something is it's big and moving fast
and has a lot of energy it's dangerous
you want to get up there with the
biggest gun you got below the crack up I
mean it is an
knee-jerk reaction was we've kind of got
that in the form of nuclear weapons but
what it does not understand when it does
not take into account is the fact that
orbital mechanics operates in such a way
that very very subtle changes in the
order to something over time they can
enough of a difference of you can in a
very controlled way miss the earth and
there's no need to be in elegant about
secondly you know if you're going to
depend upon nuclear weapons suit is sick
number one they all help you land mine
asteroids or do any science on an
asteroid all that you would blow the
crap out of it which may not work by the
way which is one of the biggest problems
but the second thing is that the other
techniques offer a possibility of lots
of other things which you're going to do
a lot more frequently than you're going
to deflect asteroids but the worst part
about it is that that means nuclear
weapons is excuse and this is one of the
motivations underneath some of the
people who are arguing this side of it
it becomes an excuse to weaponize space
and for me that personally that's a
definite but there are some people and
we can all name names who would like
nothing more that have good US weapons
nuclear weapons in space so here is an
excuse for in fact the Chinese to some
extent have already mentioned needles as
the reason for the appropriate Leader
Harry so I like the elegant solution
with one of those names be rumsfeld he
said had this is rachelle TV show me
your show me stand up Thank You Phil me
asks if Astros are like marshmallows how
are they able to impact the planets so
forcefully she'll be the best way I can
I could illustrate that first of all I
want you to picture yourself in a vacuum
ok and let me say when something is
moving as you that 20 kilometers per
second for 47,000 miles an hour put
yourself in a vacuum down and have a
marshmallow come at you and think you
have 47,000 miles an hour well I think
you can picture that that isn't going to
feel like a salt marsh money that's it
that's going to go right through your
head and make a hole exactly the size of
the marshmallow the acts of so you know
fluff going at 47,000 miles an hour is
extremely dangerous the atmosphere for
something as I said 70 70 meters in
diameter it comes partway through the
atmosphere and the heating and all the
rest of it is such that a little dis
integrate but as soon as you get up to
150 200 400 meters in diameter the
atmosphere doesn't even exist I mean
this is nothing like it's not there at
all an asteroid of that kind of burgonia
400-meter asteroid
example will throw down into the bottom
of the ocean at the deepest point of the
ocean all the way down through the whole
Aleutian hit the bottom lock and you're
going to have an explosion which creates
a huge hole in the ocean that's where
title in culture of water rushing back
into that cabin that's created by so I
didn't come off the tractor but the fact
that it's a marshmallow makes no
difference at all is the mass and the
velocity which is the energy by the mass
times square the velocity cut yeah
you're going to get the energy of that
marshmallow and it's the energy that
ultimately counts here's a question from
Eli is sherry energy and probably
announcing that wrong thank you hello
who will fund the project to move an
asteroid in the future what is the cost
of the project like that should UN or
other international organizations get
involved that's the softball across the
plate chest-high person is ready some of
the things I've written I was a very
good question and the answer is we don't
have the slightest clue put yourself in
the position of Spain well maybe
somebody else make it almost anybody
else
going to hit in your country the US
Department of Defense's trust us we got
it don't worry about you don't believe
that you feel good about that if you're
a rocky if you're a rainy or whoever the
enemy of the day is NASA the United
Nations isn't going about the program we
don't have any idea there is no answer
to that question and not only that
everybody is avoiding it like the plague
so there's number one there's no answer
at the moment we don't care about that
because we think and I say we use Excel
template you think that the most
important thing that can be done right
now and therefore we should relate is to
demonstrate this capability at NASA can
demonstrate the capability so the
immediate task is to push Bassett to
demonstrate that humanity can take
charge of its future now NASA top of the
do it but they can demonstrate the
capability and that is number one
important however look at that path of
deflection that I show
when you start pushing this asteroid if
you fail the engine fails if you ball
out the weather now you've dragged them
off Spain and across to the UK and now
you fail oh my god there goes one so who
decides what the path the actual path of
deflection is